I can't stop thinking about the time I
spent with you this filled rests in the
chemistry and you guys nailed that was
that instant or more of a slow burn I
was sort of there
from the beginning reading real-life
couple Michael Fassbender and Alicia
vikander play married in their new film
the light between the oceans but their
relationship was brewing before they
even hit the set we have Magic Mountain
Toronto Film Festival and the Baptist
just on the dawn story
he's driving really where all great
meetings happen that's right yeah you're
a good dancer cuz I saw you once it is
see I don't that too until she started
dancing and then I felt like I had two
left feet on it and the compliments
didn't stop there it's like you know
she's very fierce performer and very
brave you know as you're testing the
boundaries so far you can go and that's
Gina she definitely you know got all of
those things in spades
you can't fake this chemistry I was like
well good job haha
what is this thing now you know
you